we'd been warned but this was the first
time that we realized something was
happening gunfire followed by people
running
police vehicles suddenly appearing on
the streets that were emptying fast
within minutes helicopter gunships
appeared over the presidential palace
and government buildings in the center
of kabul
anti-missile systems firing chaff into
the air
the taliban had entered the city and the
american pilots knew it
for hours they circled above but there
was nothing they could do to stop the
takeover of the capital
occasional gunfire ripped through the
air throughout the day chinook
helicopters fed united states embassy
staff to the international airport
road moves deemed far too dangerous
it hart back to the images of the
ignominious retreat of the us from
vietnam
an image president biden said wouldn't
be repeated
but this still photograph may well come
back to haunt the president in the days
to
in
come
crowds gathered to welcome the taliban
they greeted speakers with enthusiasm
so we're going to hear a lot of shouting
near the presidential palace i watched
as the taliban entered the very heart of
this country's government i think it's a
procession of uh
of the taliban
yes it is there's the white flag
and uh
they're coming down uh the street
uh just next to us
inside the presidential palace they
rammed home this remarkable takeover
posing in the offices of power
a power that after two decades of trying
has failed to finish them
the tension in kabul has been a bursting
point as we left our hotel to see what
was going on the taliban were right in
front of us
they stared but let us pass
it won't be like this for long
these streets are usually heaving with
people and cars they were deserted
traffic jams are a permanent fixture
here the reason army and police
checkpoints
now though we pass through unimpeded
these heavily armed mini fortresses now
unmanned
once again the afghan soldiers have
melted away
well in just a
very short while after the arrival of
the taliban and
news that spread through the city the
streets are really empty i mean we were
here uh uh only
a day or so ago and in the hours from
this morning we could see it was
absolutely
shock about with people
now uh
it's uh it's it's pretty quiet
pretty empty a lot of people have just
gone home
there's no real sort of
authority on the streets anymore
this population knows what's coming
some of the changes are subtle no jeans
and t-shirts now they've changed into
traditional shower comes clothing and
there's no women to be seen
and no images of women on beauty salon
windows either
whitewashed even as the president talked
like he was still in charge
there is a clear need that the national
directorate of security alongside the
police and afghan army take
responsibility of the security of all
citizens as per my order to the defence
minister and the interior minister it is
our responsibility and god willing we
will carry out the responsibility in its
best manner
the president's words of security infer
order
at the airport there wasn't much of that
to be seen
there's a mad scramble to get on flights
that have been cancelled and onto
military flights to which there's no
access
the roads clogged with traffic and
afghan military vehicles
moving in all directions but mainly away
from the taliban
on the roadside the latest arrivals from
battles around the country drag their
belongings along the dusty roads looking
for somewhere to stay
none will forget the day the taliban
returned
their twenty year war
is won
stuart ramsey sky news kabul